viewers can get pretty confused by a
film like one flew over the cuckoo's
nest
did max revolution actually make a
difference what was chief trying to
accomplish
does nurse ratchet represent women in
the 1960s
here's some insight into the ending of
the classic film
billy bibbitt is a soft-spoken young man
with thoughts of killing himself but he
doesn't choose to end his life all on
his own
nurse ratchet talks him into it when
mack throws a party on the ward with two
sex workers he encourages billy to make
his move on candy and who made expressed
interest during the boat trip
got beautiful beautiful hair candy who's
likely used to her clients treating her
badly seems genuinely flattered when
billy stutters out as compliments
their excursion in the supply closet is
clearly more than just a meaningless
flank
that doesn't matter to nerves ratchet
ratchet knows precisely what she's doing
when she eviscerates the self-confidence
that mac has been trying to bolster in
the young man making him feel shame for
his actions
instead of addressing the situation in a
healthy or helpful way she threatens to
tell his mom
and the damn holding back billy's
self-loathing breaks as someone who
likes to get a rise out of her patients
during therapy
ratchet delights in setting off the
conditions that landed him in the
hospital to begin with
while her goal may not have been for
billy to die she knows her manipulation
will finally set mack off and allow her
to regain control over the war
billy's death is acceptable collateral
damage for ratchet if she can get what
she wants
a reason to lobotomize mcmurphy and to
use billy as an example of what happens
when you rebel
every time someone has an intimate
interaction in the film the characters
in cuckoo's nest get punished whether
it's on the ship when matt goes below
deck with candy and the patient's panic
can almost crash the boat or the way
ratchet gets manipulative and hostile
anytime someone discusses lovemaking
during group
billy's punishment is death when he
loses his virginity to candy
this is an outdated tv and film trope
that is especially prevalent during
periods when society browns hardest upon
expressions of libido in 1963 when the
film is set
the hippie movement was just beginning
and it continued through 1975 when the
film debuted
along with the idea of peace and making
strides to end the vietnam war
embracing free love was a huge aspect to
the movement which was one reason some
other parts of society shunned the
hippie lifestyle
characters like ratchet who are
completely unwilling to embrace change
represent the idea that promiscuity is a
punishable sin
in short ratchet wins and mack loses
chief represents the one small victory
of mcmurphy's attempt to liven the war
but everyone else falls right back in
line with the status quo
no one fights back and ratchet uses
electroshock therapy and lobotomies as
weapons rather than cures
seafeld says after mack has been missing
for a while
mcmurphy has escaped
[Music]
they were taking him through the tunnel
he beat up two of the attendants and
escaped
it's easier for the patients to delude
themselves into thinking that mac
escapes so they can continue to revere
him as a legend
it's comforting that escape is possible
even though they don't plan to do it
themselves
when harding tells seatbelt that mac is
upstairs getting punished he and the
rest of the patients are quick to deny
it and everyone's asleep when the order
leaves drag him back to the ward after
his lobotomy
it's unclear if the ward at large ever
finds out what really happened to mack
but when the credits roll ratchet and
her dominion over the ward have
undoubtedly won
mcmurphy's revolution impacts chief more
than anyone else in the ward by watching
mack refuse to take anything lying down
chief learns how to be as big in his
actions as he is in stature and he feels
like he owes that to mcmurphy without
the con man giving him the confidence
to talk and break free from the warts
toxic environment chief would still be
silently sweeping the hospital floors
chief knows that someone like mcmurphy
who is so full of life would never want
to live after being lobotomized
being a prisoner on ratchet's ward was
hard enough for mack without being a
prisoner of his own body
i gotta get out of here
i can't chief understands that feeling
better than most as he lived for years
silently taking insults cut off from
socialization and going through the
monotonous motions without feeling like
he could be himself
witnessing mcmurphy forced into that
type of existence is too much for chief
after a goodbye hug chief makes the
choice he believes mcmurphy would make
for himself by suffocating him with a
pillow
the scene is hard to watch as max body
involuntarily fights back
but chief succeeds and he finally feels
like he's done all he can do on the ward
escaping ratchet's reach
mack represents freedom and
self-empowerment in the ward while his
presence in the film version of the
story doesn't have the long-term
impact on most patients that he would
have liked his refusal to give up and
quest for freedom fuels the plot
there are several ways that chief can
escape the war but he picks the most
dramatic way possible
mack would have loved it when mcmurphy
tries to pick up the control panel in
the tub room earlier in the film he
fails but he still makes an almost
ridiculous effort to move it
while he's red and out of breath from
his pointless attempt he says
i tried didn't i at least i did that
[Applause]
in mac's opinion no one in the ward ever
does anything to help themselves or
change their situation and at this point
he doesn't even have a firm grasp on the
risks involved with patients standing up
for themselves
even with his schemes to swindle them
out of money he does care about his
fellow patients
as one final way to honor his fallen
friend chief succeeds in ripping the
control panel off its stand and chucking
it out the window to make his escape
he reaches the freedom max strived for
while trying something new and
succeeding
even if he failed mack would have been
proud that he tried she finally felt big
and he acted on it
ratchet faces no consequences for her
actions including lobotomizing a patient
whose crime was lashing out the woman
primarily responsible for the death of
his close friend
ratchet's victory in the ward highlights
the stigma that surrounds mental health
patients
a larger problem in the mental health
industry even today is the failure to
listen to and respect the wishes of
psychiatric patients
earlier in the movie ratchet makes a
pointed threat when mcmurphy dares to
ask which medicine the orderlies are
giving him
but anyone has a right to know what
they're putting in their bodies it's the
staff's job to work with patients to
determine as a team what medicine is
helping
if the medication is doing more harm
than good or the side effects are too
much to bear
instead she just threatens them if they
ask questions about whether the pills
are helping or hurting
ratchet has the entire ward hardwired to
do her bidding and no amount of patient
lobotomies or deaths seem to lead to any
kind of reckoning for her
because who are the authorities going to
believe the decorated war nurse or the
psych patients
nurse ratchet manipulates the ward's
staff through fear just as much as she
plays god with her patients
no one stands up to her even when they
can see that there's something wrong
ratchet holds all the cards for who gets
released and who gets life-altering
procedures
nothing on the ward happens without her
say-so it wasn't until the feminist
movement ramped up in the 1960s that the
number of working women in the u.s
rose significantly while many single
women were in the workforce in 1930
only about 12 percent of married women
worked that number rose to about 50
percent by 1970.
after picking up various jobs while men
were serving in the military in world
war ii
married women found purpose in
employment and many fought to keep
working after the war ended
many men weren't thrilled with this and
campaigned to keep women in their place
as homemakers
given the stigma it's not a shock that
the film depicts working women in a bad
light
viewers could definitely interpret
ratchet's power-hungry manipulation of
the ward as a fear-mongering depiction
of all the awful things that can happen
when a woman is in charge
patients frequently accuse ratchet of
taking away their manhood when they rant
to each other
a point further driven home by the shot
of ratchet smiling after forcing mac
into a lobotomy
iguas monas won a nobel prize for
inventing a procedure that would go on
to leave 50 000 patients in the u.s
alone
either dead or virtually comatose in
1949 he modified earlier attempts at
brain alteration procedures to create
the locotomy one year later walter
freeman brought the surgery to the u.s
renaming it the lobotomy the procedure
involved what was essentially an ice pit
going through the eye to get to the
brain instead of drooling through the
head
often touted as a miracle cure the
horrific procedure was supposed to help
patients control their emotions
instead it left them with virtually no
emotions at all
in an interview with life science
medical historian and professor dr
barron lerner referred to a lobotomy's
after-effect as mental dullness
saying most patients could no longer
live independently and they lost their
personalities
learner praised one flew over the
cuckoo's nest for its accurate depiction
of the procedure
calling it disturbingly real the novel
one flew over the cuckoo's nest was
published in 1962
during the height of the lobotomy's
acceptable use walter freeman performed
his last lobotomy in 1967
five years after the film takes place by
its 1975 release he'd been dead for
three years
so why was this story still important to
tell author ken
kesey worked as a nurse's aide in a
psychiatric ward at a veterans hospital
in 1960 which inspired his novel
that year dr freeman performed a
lobotomy on the youngest patient ever to
receive one a 12 year old boy named
howard dulle
dully survived growing up to become a
bus driver dully told
npr if you saw me you'd never know i'd
had a lobotomy but i've always felt
different
wondered if something's missing from my
soul lobotomies were on the decline by
the time keyse wrote one flew over the
cuckoo's nest
and were banned in the u.s by the time
the film was released the message was
clear though
far too many patients were subjected to
life-altering procedures and psychiatric
wards with little say in what happened
to them
we see it when ratchet manipulates billy
with details she shouldn't share about
his care
we see it when the nurse forces mack
into electroshock therapy and a lobotomy
we see it in the way the hospital staff
uses fear of these procedures to control
the war
we see time and time again that the
staff cares more about power and
dominance than the patient's health
how cruel and ineffective the lobotomy
treatment was as a powerful ending to
get readers and viewers to care about
mental health and the ramifications of
poor
treatment hospitals still face massive
overcrowding
patients often have to wait days weeks
or even months for bed an award or even
an appointment
even for severe cases of suicidal
ideation or conditions like
schizophrenia
while the lobotomy has been outlawed in
the u.s for decades a modern version of
the procedure called psychosurgery is
still occasionally performed today
mental health care has come a long way
since the 50s but there's still work to
do
if you or someone you know is having
suicidal thoughts please call the
national suicide prevention lifeline at
1-800-273-talk
8255 or text home to the crisis text
line at 741
741